Elise stefanik who is an absolutely
horrible Republican member of Congress
went on Fox News and remember due
process law and auto Law and Order
whatever they call it these days she
went on Fox News and said I believe Joe
Biden committed multiple criminal acts
really wow based on what evidence and
you have them trying to protect Joe
Biden who has I believe committed
multiple criminal acts there's going to
come to a point where they're going to
have to report on it absolutely all
right thank you so much chairwoman for
coming thank you by the way not going to
ask a question about is that due process
is that Law and Order Elise I believe
that the president has committed
multiple criminal acts although I have
no evidence so let's now dig into this
one and then we're going to really be
able to say we did it and I don't want
to hear any more from the Maga people
the insistence that Joe Biden
is a crook
is not backed by any evidence at this
point in time they say it
to try to counter balance
documentary
photographic and sworn eyewitness
evidence of Donald Trump's criminality
Trump is innocent until proven guilty
but there's an indictment based on 37
felony counts mishandling obstructing
making false statements Etc the Biden
classified documents incident is based
on the discovery of a few dozen
classified documents some from when
Biden was in the Senate some from the
era of the Obama Administration at
Biden's former office and home
there's a special counsel investigating
it the Special counsel hasn't finished
yet I'm fine saying if the special
counsel finds evidence that Joe Biden
did something illegal then charge the
guy however that's not actually the path
that that investigation is going and
we're going to get to that in a moment
Trump's indictment says he was sharing
classified documents as I said with
people who weren't authorized to see
them improperly storing them directing
lawyers and aides to lie and hide and
obstruct and Destroy he had toilet
documents a huge dump of documents right
by his toilet all these different things
Biden's document incident involves
records that were inadvertently
misplaced in a locked closet at his
former office and some in his garage at
home the White House has said as soon as
we figured that out we immediately
turned it over and have been cooperating
fully with the doj that is not what
Donald Trump did and much of what Trump
is charged with is in that aftermath
it's the cover-up for lack of a better
term Trump defied requests as I told you
made false statements as I told you told
aids to hide and obstruct as I told you
Biden's classified documents don't
involve a single allegation of lying or
a single allegation of obstruction of
justice why because Biden didn't do
those things he's been he has not been
accused of any wrongdoing or charged at
this time
Trump's indictment could result in
prison time we don't know yet but it
could Biden's classified document
incident by all legal assessments that
make sense not by Mark Levin or Tom
fitton but by people who actually are
taking this seriously Biden's
consequences could be administrative
sanctions or in theory he could have a
security clearance revoked even though
he's president if it finds if the
investigation finds that he was
negligent or behaved improperly then of
course we have the Biden bribery stuff I
already talked about Biden bribery
earlier so we've now looked at Biden
bribery we've looked at Biden classified
documents we've looked at Hillary
classified documents we've done it all
okay if anybody is found to have likely
committed a crime I'm the first to say
charge them but it would be wrong for me
to tell you that that's the direction
these things are pointing those are the
facts no matter how many times Maga
trumpists starts screaming about it